die kapitalausflüsse haben wir seit
Jahrzehnten sie sind das Spiegelbild der
Exportstärke wir reden über
Diversifikation das Unternehmen im
Ausland investieren um sich Giger
aufzustellen Teilhabe am werkstum von
China USA haben also diese Ausflüsse
sind etwas total positiv das Problem
sind die zu geringen Investitionen
deutscher Unternehmen in Deutschland das
ist das Problem das deutsche Unternehmen
sich diversifizieren also diese
Ausflüsse das ist etwas durch und durch
gutes wir wollen gute Arbeitsplätze in
Deutschland halt und dafür müssen
Unternehmen sich global aufstellen dort
produzieren wo sie es am günstigsten
können Vorleistung da h beziehen deshalb
ist das die große Stärke Deutschlands
dass wir wirklich global aufgestellt
sind wir wachsen schwächer wir haben
demografische Probleme unsere Stärke ist
Teilhabe am Wachstum in den
schnellwachsenden Volkswirtschaften zu
haben deshalb sind diese Investitionen
im Ausland etwas Gutes nochmals das
Problem sind das deutsche Unternehmen zu
wenig in Deutschland investieren ganz
unabhängig von den investien im aus